فادي مراسل له العربيه في فرنسا بان نيابه
العامه تطلب حبسه منفذ الهجوم على المركز
الكردي بباريس مؤقتا ياتي ذلك مع انطلاق
تظاهرات حاشده للجاليه الكرديه تنديدا
باعتداء الدائره العاشره والذي اودى بحياه
ثلاثه اكراد مراسل العربيه افاد كذلك بان
السلطات اغلقت الشوارع المحيطه بالتظاهرات
الكرديه مضيفا ان النيابه العامه الفرنسيه
طلبت حبسه منفذ الهجوم على المركز الكردي
بباريس مؤقتا
ينضم ولينا مراسل العربيه حسين قنيبر من
الدائره العاشره في باريس حيث وقع
الاعتداء بريئه حسين مرحبا بك معي في هذه
النشره اذا كما ذكرت النيابه العامه طلبت
حبسه منفذ هذا الهجوم يوم الجمعه الماضيه
بحبسه بباريس مؤقتا ماذا لديك من معلومات
وتفاصيل حول ما جرى حتى هذه اللحظه موتوله
كذلك امام القضاء
النعم في الواقع هو كان وضع قيد الحبس
الاحتياطي بعد توقيفه من قبل الشرطه بعيده
تنفيذه الاعتداء الثلاثيه يوم الجمعه بعد
يومين من الحبس الاحتياطي خضع لفحصن لوضعه
النفسي احيل بعده بطلب من طبيبه نفسي احيل
على
مصحن نفسه تابع لشرطه باريس همم كان ذلك
يوم السبت ومساء امس اعيد الى وضعيه الحبس
الاحتياطي هذه الوضعيه انتهت صباح اليوم
وحول بعد موتها امام قاضي الى وضعيه الحبس
المؤقت تمهيدا لاحالته الى تحقيق التنسيق
حاليا بين قسم مكافحه الارهاب في الشرطه
الفرنسيه والنيابه العامه لتحديد ما اذا
كان مقام به هو اعتداء عنصري ام انه عمل
ارهابي وضعه نفسي سيحدد العقوبه التي
ستفرض عليه اذا كان مسؤولا جزائيا ستكون
طبي عقوبه مختلفه اما اذا كان وضعه النفسي
يبرر عدم مسئوليته جزائيا ستكون هناك
عقوبه مختلفه في هذا الشارع عند هذه
الجاده بالاحرى كانت التظاهر الضخمه التي
انطلقت خلال مداخله معك في النشره ما قبل
السابقه خالد انفضت التظاهره قبل قليل من
الان هي لم تستمر اكثر من ساعه وربع ساعه
بطلب من المنظمين الاكراد الذين ارادوا
اعطاء صوره ايجابيه لينفو عن انفسهم
الرغبه في التخريب وهم يسرون على ان من
قاموا بالتخريب هم مجموعه من المشاغبين
الذين ليسوا بالضروره كلهم على علاقه
بالاحتجاج الكردي اعترفوا بانه كان هناك
غضب كردي نعم انفجر الغضب النتيجه عدم
حمايه السلطات الفرنسيه بما يكفي للاكراد
هنا خصوصا ان عمليه قتل ثلاثيه كانت جاره
ايضا في التاسع من يناير من عام 2013 ولم
يحاسب المسؤول عنها حتى الان معي الناطقه
باسم الحركه هي الكرديه الحركه النسائيه
الكرديه هنا حاضره جدا في هذا التحرك وفي
كل التحركات بوجوه
وديزيا مدام
يستطيع ان يركع الاكراد وسيبقى راسهم
مرفوعا بس همم
عام 2013
اقول لها ولكن هذه المره الاعتداء عنصري
وانت تتهمين تركيا اشرحي لنا ايليا ناتشر
كده
خلف هذا الاغتيال الى بيسي انه دونك
مع من كان يتحدث في السجن ولماذا تحول
عدائه من المهاجرين الى الاكلات تحديدا
اندير نيمو
الفرنسي والاوروبي
تغلق الشوارع من كل الجهات تشاهد سيارات
الشرطه من بعيد عند المقلب الاخر من
الشارع الكلمات التي تعاقب المسؤولون
الاكراد على القائها تشدد نايف اخيرا على
ان الرئيس ماكرون يمكنه ان يلعب دورا في
حل القضيه الكرديه وذكر المتحدثون ان
فرنسا ايضا كانت مستهدفه في هذا الاعتداء
وانا احدا لن يكون بامكانه ان يجبر
الاكراد على الركوع سيواصلون النظام حتى
اخر كردي كما قال احد المتحدثين حرفيا قبل
قليل من هنا
التي وقع الاعتداء الثلاثي الجمعه فيها في
شارع المجاور للمكان الذي انا موجود فيه
حسين الصوره مختلفه الان عن المباشر الذي
ظهرت همم معي فيه يعني عند ثالثه او ثاني
بتوقيت همم السعوديه الحاديه عشر بتوقيت
جرينتش اختلفت تماما الصوره هل يعني ذلك
بان هذه المظاهرات انتهت تماما اما ان
هناك ايضا جدول همم ربما يومي او شبه يومي
هذه المظاهرات لمطالبات الجاريه الكرديه
في همم باريس من المتوقع ان تحدث خلال
الفتره القادمه
في الواقع التظاهره كان مخططا لها ان
تستمر اكثر من ما استمرت بالفعل لان قرار
صدر عن المسؤولين الاكراد باختصار وقت
التظاهرات تجنبا لحدوث اي صدام وتجنبا لان
يندس مجددا مشاغبون في صفوف التظاهرات
اللي للقيام باعمال تخريب المسؤولون
الاكراد اعترفوا بان الغضب الذي انفجر
تجاوزهم واقر بان البعض قام باعمال شغب من
هنا كان حرصهم على تظاهرات هادئه اليوم في
باريس مع اشاره اخيره لو سمحت لايف ان
الذي جرى يوم السبت الماضي كان اسفر عن
جرح واحد وثلاثين شرطيا ومتظاهر واحد ورغم
كل ذلك السلطات الفرنسيه عبرت عن دعمها
الكامل وتفهمها للجاليه الكرديه من الرئيس
ماكرون الذي قدم تعازيه لعائلات الضحايا
الى وزير الداخليه جيرال برمانا الذي قال
ان كل التراخيص التي سيطلبها الاكراد
للتظاهر ستعطى لهم مرورا بقائد شرطه باريس
الذي استقبل وفدا من ممثلي الجاليا
الكرديه السبت ووصف اللقاء بانه كان البنا
الى وزير العدل الفرنسي ايريكا جيبون
موريتي الذي قال ان كل فرنسا في عزاء وانا
دعمنا للاكراد ثابت لا يتزعزع دعم سياسي
يترجم العلاقه الجيده بين السلطات
الفرنسيه
والاكراد هنا وهذا ما يعني دفع المسؤولين
الاكراد الى التوضيح بان اعمال الشغب
تجاوزتهم وهذا ما دفعهم الى القيام بتنظيم
التظاهر اليوم والى اختصار وقتها تجنبا
لاي صدامات تسيء الى صوره الجاليه الكرديه
في فرنسا نايف شكرا جزيلا لك من باريس
تحديدا من الدائره العاشره مراسل العربيه